[Music]
[Applause]
we started the show we talked a little
bit about what's going on with the
kentucky derby winner medina spirit
accused of using an anti-inflammatory
bob baffert is the uh the great trainer
for that horse
and uh won a couple of triple crowns won
the kentucky derby uh seven times
and bob uh joins us now bob thanks for
joining us
what have you been accused of exactly
um i've been accused of uh my horse
tested positive for
a legal therapeutic
medication it's called beta methazone
and uh it was 21 picograms which is
we call it contaminant levels um
it's a picogram they're testing at these
really low levels last few years
and so it's been a problem in racing but
the the really troubling thing is uh
dan is that the horse has never been
treated with that
uh specific drug so we're we're
at a loss for uh words trying to figure
out how
he got content got contaminated because
at those levels they call it
contamination
okay once you find out what has happened
do you do
you know inventory with your staff where
anybody could have possibly administered
this to this horse without your
knowledge
well usually it's that that specific
drug is usually
uh it's it can be injectable but uh the
horse wasn't injected with that so we're
we're going through different we checked
make sure that nobody had any special
creams you know i'm worrying about it
right now uh but nobody nobody to handle
the horse that
handle the horse had any creams or
anything like that so
we just don't know where this came from
do you think you've been sabotaged
i think i don't know if i was sabotaged
indirectly i think it could have been
somebody handled this horse touched it
because at those levels it's very minute
it's at a level that it wouldn't affect
the horse
and it's scary they're scary levels
because i've had this
of this problem before when did you find
out
that this inquiry was going on i was on
my way to uh california
on um was it's friday
saturday saturday i mean and um i got a
call from my assistant trainer
jimmy barnes in louisville and he told
me something horrible has just happened
i thought one of the horses had gotten
hurt and he says we've just been served
with that
our horse derby horse tested positive
for betamethasone
and i immediately you know called the
the stewards there and
i know what's going on it's not
something's not right
uh it's got to be and i i told them they
need to test
get hair samples immediately let's get
some dna this has to be a mistake
and it still could be i'm hoping it's a
mistake maybe it was the wrong horse or
whatever but uh
you know the it's something that i've
got an investigation team working on it
but
uh it it it's horrible dan it's
something that uh
i would you know i said i would never
risk my reputation
and i train for you know these great
horses
and and i train for great clients and
it's just it doesn't make sense
and but it's hard to you know people in
the horse industry they
they understand you know it's bs but not
the public
how beneficial would this drug be to
that horse
at that level it had zero effect on the
horse we're talking picograms it's like
it's one picogram is a salt grain
it's a billionth of a gram are you going
to uh
run the horse in the preakness well
we're planning on it
uh we're waiting to hear from uh uh
preakness came out with a statement
churchill down came out with a really
harsh statement yeah
i was shocked by it um because uh
you know i think it was just a knee-jerk
cancel culture kind of reaction
and uh and they violated my due process
i mean this
usually when these when you get a
positive man it's
it's supposed to be confidential and
they wait for your split to come back
and usually takes a few weeks and then
then they they announce it
but it leaked out immediately i've had
this happen to me a couple times it just
leaks out immediately so it i i
now now i have to fight this in the
public when do you get the second result
back
they usually come it usually takes about
three weeks for it to come back
three weeks yeah that's it's a it's a
very slow process
but will the preakness allow you if if
they don't you don't have that second
test back well they should allow me
because the horse is not officially
it has it's got to be it has to be
confirmed if there was a mistake
so basically uh they they really can't
you know
they they can't they shouldn't you know
keep them from running
can you sue to run in the preakness
uh i think there's some some we're
looking at some avenues that you know
if they do come up and say something you
know we're gonna we're gonna be
aggressive here
but if if you talk to the casual sport
fan here
bob who doesn't know horse racing they
probably say well you've got some priors
here
that that you've had other incidents
with horses so what what do you say to
the casual sports fan looking at the or
even people in the horse racing industry
here
that there have been other horses who
have failed drug tests
well i think a lot of them were just uh
you know mistakes like this is from
1971. you know
down the road i used to be a little
sloppy and they were overages they
weren't
nothing really serious and the last
couple of years i've had some like
justify
was the big one he had he ingested uh
scopolamine which it comes in the hay i
had i couldn't
prevented that and we resolved that it
was
it was a bad headline uh i had a
a groom that urinated that he had
coveted and after he's getting over he
urinated in the stall
and the horse ate it it was a cough
medicine
we resolved that and you know things
like that happen because they're testing
at these
really extremely low levels this would
not have been a positive in california
if that's the thing with racing it's not
uniform and they just change these rules
here in kentucky
because of that because of those those
levels things can happen
then in arkansas i had uh lidocaine
positives last year
and one of my uh in the arkansas derby
and another horse
and then we found out that we just
resolved that because there was other
horses that tested positive
in the arkansas derby that were right
below the threshold so
they got contaminated within 45 minutes
of the race so
these things happen to pick up but when
they're testing at this new level they
just started this
because everybody's like you know racing
has been in this
we've got to clean up the sport and
they've got this new horse racing
integrity act and i was one of the guys
first
trainers behind it so i think it's good
let's we need somebody and we
i welcome like a travis tiger to come in
and and and see this and to explain the
people if we had them
then the people say well you know if
they're looking at it
we need people like from the outside
looking in because the regulators that
we have right now
they just don't use common sense you
know it's it's getting really bad
where's the horse right now the horse is
actually in a van headed to uh
preakness uh to pimlico we usually fly
him there but the uh
the the cargo company uh
just lost their leave so uh so they're
they
they had a van there so this is the
first time i've ever been there i think
it takes about 10 hours
is there sabotage though in the industry
like you're saying you could be like is
there
people are there people out there that
are that are trying to
taint these these drug tests i i'm
starting to i've never been a conspiracy
theorist but i'm starting to suspect it
it's been happening to me on on the big
day you know and so
and we have really we have the security
we're watching them i mean these horses
live
they don't live in a boat you know their
environment there's their stalls it's
open
you know it's people can walk through
and you know at any time
we don't really you know we're not
thinking but it's just
it just seems really strange now that
here's a horse that didn't get that
specific drug he was not treated with
that and
it's uh it you know it's
it's that's what that's mind-boggling
right there that somebody
either had to contaminate him somewhere
so
i we just don't know that i i hate to
speculate but
we don't know what do you think happens
today what are you working on today
today we're working on uh on maryland on
like uh
the preakness we're trying to figure out
uh they're gonna have the draw they're
supposed
to i guess notify me i haven't been told
anything
you know uh i just know what you what we
read
so i'm just waiting to hear my uh i have
uh
my lawyers you know watching it closely
what's going on and so uh
the um that's all we do is sit and wait
uh if officials are watching right now
from the derby or preakness what would
you say to them
i would say you know i didn't
i didn't administer that the horse
didn't get my i'm an open book
i'm a hall of fame trainer i had a lot
of success
and a lot of people are out there you
know just they don't like it
you know that's part of the part of the
game i understand it
but i didn't do it and it's just
it's they need to look at this in a
different way it shouldn't have been
called a positive and they know
it's a contaminant level and we've been
dealing with this
and i keep saying you know racing has a
lot of problems but bob baffert isn't
one of them
but you know with success comes a lot of
um
jealousy and animosity and uh but i'm an
open book i'm gonna
i'm very transparent they they look at
all the vet records we we
present everything to them i've never
we're an open book
bob thanks for joining us uh good luck
with the challenge there
we'll certainly be uh watching we
appreciate your time
thank you dan that's uh bob baffert the
uh hall of fame trainer
and still waiting to see if they'll be
able to uh
enter the horse at the preakness you
just gotta sit and wait